pour tirer sur sa bouffarde prière de
s'évacuer au grand air allumer son clope
à l'intérieur c'est terminé maintenant
c'est dehors qu'on tire sur le mégot
après la fac de dentaire le centre de
langues l'iut les locaux de droit voilà
que le site de la 106 vient de tomber
aux mains des non fumeurs on espère la
création de deux salles avec extracteurs
pour que pour lui la cohabitation se
passe bien on veut surtout pas d'une
société à l'américaine où watsco plus
mal pas ou du moins ceux qui fument pas
et puis bon état sont sous un temps
comme ça être dérangeante
ouais c'est normal a pas marché ce qui
fût ce que tu as envie de fumer mais
nous faut pas confier non plus pas vrai
qu'on trouve une salle qui quoi voilà
tout le monde est sympa et les
cigarettes sont virés de la sensive
alors pour fêter ça une joyeuse troupe
de crash heuer et de catatonie compte
déambuler pour annoncer la nouvelle aux
étudiants